Hey, this is Emily Valani and
I'm calling from Austin, Texas.
Radiolab is supported
by dash digital cash,
a revolutionary form of money that allows
anyone anywhere to make instant secure
payments. Dash is digital
cash. For more information,
visit [inaudible] dot
org slash radio lab now
[inaudible]
no. Okay. No,
I listen to radio
[inaudible]
[inaudible] I'll continue with here.
Report the first large scale study
comparing the prevalence of absolute pitch
into normal populations by
means of professor Diana
Deutsch. Deutsch, why? Yeah,
I'm going to turn down my head phone.
[inaudible] I'm a professor psychology
at the University of California San
Diego. Can you still hear
me dying? Okay. Hello.
Diana. Studies sound how humans
perceive sound. She's a scientist.
She has a lab, but every so often
she will also release cds, right?
These a cds of audio demonstrations that
she uses in her research and that's why
we called because it was in the production
of her second CD that she stumbled
onto the weirdest phenomenon. Well,
oh, I'll tell you what happened. Does
that, um, when you do post production is,
as you know of of speech,
you look things, look things.
Look things so that you
can zero in on piece. Cool.
That sound too loud. Nita, unpopular
ss, that sounds two shops and so on.
So you put things on loops in order to
fine tune the way the speech sounds.
So I had this particular phrase
on a loop and forgot about it.
What phrase was,
this is a phrase that occurs at the
beginning of the CD in which I say the
sounds as they appear to you and not
only different from those that are really
present,
but they sometimes behave so
strangely as to seem quite impossible,
quite impossible.
Now I had sometimes behave so strangely
looped the sounds as they appear to you
are not only different from
those that are really present,
but they sometimes behave so strangely
sometimes behave so strangely.
Just those few words sometimes behave
so strangely and forgot about sometimes
behave so strangely,
sometimes behave so strange.
So here's what happened. Diana leaves
her studio, she closes the door,
it goes into the kitchen to
make some tea. All the wild.
This loop is worrying
away in the background
as she's sipping her tea.
She thinks sometimes is someone
singing strangely who's singing?
I heard what sounded like song
in the background. Wait a second,
that's not singing.
That's me talking that
very phrase strangely.
But at this point sometimes
behave so straight.
Appear to be sung rather
than spoken strangely.
Sometimes behave so strangely.
This is sometimes behave
so strangely, right?
You still hear the words but there are
some words rather than spoken words.
It's weird like it just
switches it a certain point,
three or four repetitions
in, right? It's going,
it's going and then pow
becomes music and then now,
now none of us can get it out of our head.
Like the whole office is like
sometimes VA. So strange sometimes VA.
So strangely
and you know what if you do this demo
and then you go back to the original
sentence, it sounds like you
know speech to begin with.
And when you come to that very phrase
as seem to be bursting into song,
the sounds as they appear to you are
not only different from those that are
really present,
but they sometimes behave so
strangely as to seem quite impossible.
I have to say this can
continue for months and months.
I sort of sort of like your brain gets
altered for that particular phrase and it
continues to sound like
singing for a very,
very long time. [inaudible]
alright, so here we have just one
small indication that music is crazy.
Will it behaves very strangely,
right? I mean think about this.
We started with some basic
speech repeated a few times.
Somewhere along the way it
leaped into song strangely.
How did it change like that and if that's
all it takes to turn something into
music. And what exactly is music really?
Sometimes we hate. So same
thing. This is Radiolab.
Today's program is about answering
that question or trying to,
in any case some chat
up. I'm rod here with me.
[inaudible] Robert Krulwich my partner.
I think it a little hard to get out of
your head. I know. It is really cool.
I know. Yeah. Okay. So this
hour, what are we doing?
We are going to try and we will probably
fail. You will ask. We will fail,
but we will make an earnest effort to
try to find the ingredients of music.
Both its basis in languages basis in
physics is basis in your brain will look
everywhere we can software trying to
find out what music is made of and why it
touches us so intimately,
so strange, so strange and touches
us sometimes. Not In a good way.
If you've ever had this
experience of going to a concert,
hearing some music and it just
made you upset for some reason,
like irrationally upset, right? Almost
like you wanted to hurt someone.
If that rings a bell, there's
a segment later in the show,
you will not want to miss [inaudible].
[inaudible]
this is Radiolab. Stick around.
Eh,
a pretty messed up.
Shall we start?
Sure. Well first, thanks to the LaGuardia
High School Chorus and Robert Apostle,
they were the voices you just heard.
Hi Baby. Hey, we're
here. More of them later.
So let's explore a little bit more closely
this connection between language and
music. You think of them as separate.
The thing is they're really closely
related, says neuroscientists, mark,
Jude tremble when we speak. We Sing,
you'd know how to use the pitch of your
voice to convey emotion and meaning
like, um,
I went to the store just
because I raised the pitch.
The note, if you will, you
interpret that as an interrogative,
a monotonic speech, you know,
talking at the same rate and rhythm
in the same pitch and loudness.
I mean that is not how humans talk,
but humans talking to all kinds of
different ways in different languages.
Each language has its
own musical personality.
German is different than French is
different than Swahili and if you look at
those differences closely,
there are all kinds of things we can
learn about music. Tick Diana Deutsch.
Okay. She's recently been
looking at tone languages,
just published her results and
the results are startling. Diana,
before we start, what
exactly is it? Tone language.
Okay. In 10 languages,
words take on different meanings
depending upon the tone in which they are
enunciated. For example,
Mandarin has four tones and the word mar
in Mandarin means mother in the first
tone,
hemp in the second tone horse in the
third tone and a reproach in the fourth
tone. Could you say the name?
Would you like me to? Yeah.
Could you just say you were,
I thought you were well up.
You know I had them on CD, but I'd
rather hear you say them well. Um, okay.
So excuse my bad
pronunciation without trying.
[inaudible] means Martha Ma means hemp.
Ma means horse and Ma is a reproach.
Huh? [inaudible]
so conceivably if you screwed up the
tones you could call your mom a horse.
Yes, indeed. In fact,
there are quite a lot of jokes where
westerners who don't speak the tones,
right? Say terrible things.
[inaudible] you have to be
very careful. [inaudible]
see this is a basic difference in English.
We don't really worry about pitch.
We can see our words up here or down here
or glycerin up or bended down and it's
all the same. Not so with
tone languages. In any case,
this is where it gets interesting.
One day Diana is working
with some mandarin speakers
and she notices something.
There were these words,
these words that they would say where
they would all hit precisely the same note
with their voices, not just close
to one another either. Exactly,
precisely and consistently the
same pitch even on different days.
In fact,
would you like me to play for you one
person reciting a list of 12 mandarin
tones on two different
days? Yeah, definitely. Um,
first you have the first
word spoken on. Yeah,
day one followed by the same
word spoken and teachers yell.
Then you have the second word spoken on
Day one, jaw followed by the same word,
spoken day two [inaudible]
way here you can see the consistency is
going to appear as though the words are
being repeated immediately.
Like in fact the repetitions are
coming entirely different days.
So each of those word pairs came out
of the mouth of one person separated by
like 24 hours. Oh, much more than
that. Something like a week. Really.
And it was a remarkable
consistency Jean gene.
Well that'd be like a sane, the word
mom always at this note right here, mom,
mom, mom.
I concluded that basically this
was a form of perfect pair.
Sure.
[inaudible] she should be [inaudible]
I've never quite understood what
perfect pitch is to be honest.
You don't know what that is.
No. Should I, and I know I should,
but whisper it to me as a musician
growing up. Perfect pitches like that.
It's like the thing,
it's like the thing you wish you
had and none of us have basically.
It's like having a tuning
fork in your brain here.
I'll give you an analogy. Yeah. Okay. You
see this Coffee Cup I'm holding? Yeah.
What color is it? Brown. And you
knew that how? Through my eyes.
Right. You didn't need me to put this
Brown Coffee Cup next to my blue jeans.
No, I didn't have to see the Brown. I
mean it's absolute brown. Absolute Brown.
Perfect pitch. People have that
with pitch. They hear a pitch.
They knew exactly what note it is.
The rest of us have to run to the piano.
So if the hero from an elevator,
can they name the note?
Yeah, that's exactly it. Anything
with a pitch like a horn honk,
they could tell you that horn is
enough. Or those church bells,
they're alternating between B flat
and B and if the faucet were dripping,
they could see that faucet
is dripping in. It's d sharp.
They don't even have to think about
it. They just know it used to be the,
the note names would jump out at me.
Diana Deutsch is actually one of these
lucky people to the extent that it would
even be a nuisance. And
why? Why is that good?
Well, it's really rare.
It only happens like once every 10,000
people here in America. Europe. Yeah.
And so it is turning your tongue to
a poem and of the people who have it.
Yeah. Well, let's see how
many, how should I say this?
If you look in your
music history textbook,
so you will see that every famous
composer like the really big ones, right?
[inaudible] Beethoven,
[inaudible],
they all had it when really
Mendelsohn, the list goes on and on.
So if you have perfect
pitch on some level, you are
[inaudible]
closer to them.
he's got the gift.
[inaudible] Danielle,
let's get back to Diana
Deutsch. Okay. Okay.
Let's talk about your latest experiment.
That's the one really interested in.
Okay. You see,
you compare Chinese kids to American
kids to see who has perfect pitch.
More so the, explain how this works. You
had a group of Chinese music students,
Air Group of American music students at
the Eastman School of music here in New
York.
You played them a bunch of notes I imagine
in a room and ask them to guess what
those notes were right now.
Well, the test consisted of piano tones,
which began on the c below middle c,
this note and extended up three up
gives all the way to the that note.
That's a big range. Yeah. 36 notes.
Can you demonstrate you sure. Yes.
Here is six chones. Yeah.
Hmm. Hmm. Such as where given in the test.
So you would have played those notes to
both sets of kids and asked them to name
the notes without going to the
piano. What were the notes? Really
what these notes were? D e g sharp,
c sharp, d sharp and g.
Um, what were the results?
Well,
it turns out the Chinese group far
outperformed the small group of those
students who started musical training
ages four and five 74% of the Chinese
group show. Perfect pitch.
But 14% of the US non-tariff 74% the
Beijing group was nine times roughly more
likely to show perfect pitch
than the American Jesus.
That's the [inaudible] group daggering
difference. It's a staggering difference.
Mm.
And it's your hunch that the difference
is because they speak a tone language.
That's my hat. I mean
the, it's, it's known that
the first year of life
saved for made six months up to, you know,
a little a year infants learn
features of their native language.
This is a very, very important stage.
Let's suppose that tone and the absolute
pitch of tones is a feature which is
potentially available to anyone.
Babies who are exposed only
to an international language
such as English are not
given the opportunity to acquire, chose,
then they're going to be
at a real disadvantage when
they come later on to learn
to take Whittick lessons.
So you think that as there, Huh?
[inaudible] let me ask we this,
as they're learning their language,
which includes inherently music, right?
To some degree, they are essentially
learning two languages as they learn one.
Is that right? It's a matter of fact,
if you take the first tone
[inaudible] it's a flat tone.
It's really sung compared
with English speech.
It's really more like song that's,
that's always been sort of the
stereotype of the Chinese languages.
It's very sort of sing Sony. Yes.
Tony soil mean Guido home bow share,
Lambeau Shirley bow shoe for example,
the third child in Mandarin Ma.
It's sort of like a j type pattern. The
second term, which is a gentle output,
bless Ma, the fourth child, which
is a rapid downward place ma.
I mean these are all kinds of
musical relationships. Yeah.
Given the evidence on absolute pitch,
one could speculate further said,
well maybe other features of music are
also enhanced for individuals who start
off learning tone language. So,
so the, here's my big question.
Could this explain the
experience that I had?
And I think a lot of people have this
experience when they're taking music
lessons and we were playing little
piddly pieces like [inaudible]
and here are these Chinese girls
right here playing rough monarch.
Brilliant. Yeah. Is this why? Well,
I think it's a viable hypothesis. I mean,
evidently it could be something else.
It could be something else going on.
Like what? I mean, one could argue that
instead it might be genetic and so on,
but they're seen as such a,
it's such a boring theory,
like always a boring
theory. And furthermore,
we don't have to assume that knowing what
we do about exposure to tone language
in very early childhood as
a as a, it's just not fair.
And I think we can look
at it another way around
here.
We have a faculty that had been fought
to be confined to a few rare individuals
who are just extraordinarily
gifted, right?
That might in fact be available to any
individual provided they're given the
right exposure at a critical period.
And that raises the question of what
other sorts of abilities could be brought
out if we only knew just what to do.
There may be much more human
potential than we had realized.
[inaudible]
Diana Deutsch is a professor of music
psychology at the University of San Diego,
music psychology, music psychology.
And as I mentioned earlier,
she's also the releaser of
two cds. She has two cds,
one's called musical
illusions and paradoxes.
And the other one is called Phantom
words and other curiosities.
What w what would you
put on a CD? Exactly.
She puts these little audio pieces
that she uses in her research.
The stuff I guess that she will play to
subjects as she tests them and she puts
these on cities cause they're
kind of fun to listen to.
This is like an ear
test or, yeah, sort of.
We've actually put a couple on our
website. Well what do they sound like?
We just get that little sample. All
right. I'll give you some samples. A,
there is the chromatic illusion.
Ken has a carnival feel to
it. There's also the, uh,
Biana Ellucian. Oh, the can be up illusion
and of course the phantom word
experiments. Whoa, Whoa, Whoa,
whoa, Whoa, whoa.
None of those pieces are gonna make
any kind of sense unless you visit our
website, radiolab.org
where all will be explained
[inaudible]
coming up. Fashionably French
ladies in elegant dresses.
Throw things at innocent
musicians. I'm Jad Abumrad,
maybe not so innocent wrapper. Grub
witch and I will continue to moment.